Hallöchen ihr Lieben! Wir machen heute Erdbeer Cupavci
bzw. mir hat auf Instagram eine Zuschauerin geschrieben: Es wird "Tschupavtsi" ausgesprochen.
Auf jeden Fall ist es ein bosnisches Gericht
und alle Bosnier können mir gerne mal hier unten drunter in die Kommentare schreiben, wie's denn richtig ausgesprochen wird.
Ich dachte immer "Tschupavtschi"! Was dachtest du denn, Hamza?
[Hamza] "Schupavschi"!
[Kiki] *lacht* "Schupavschi", hört sich an wie ein Pokémon!
[Hamza] Schupavschi, komm raus! Die Erdbeerattacke!
Die Erdbeerattacke, gutes Stichwort!
Und zwar machen mir Erdbeer Cupavci weil ich mir dachte das ist so sommerlich angehaucht.
Diese Schoko Cupavci waren auch super lecker.
verlinke ich euch unten in die Videobeschreibung, mache ich immer wieder gerne.
Aber ich hab mir gedacht ich wandle das Ganze jetzt einfach mal ab in Richtung Sommer, Erdbeeren etc.
Hier habe ich jetzt zuallererst meine Eier. Die werde ich zusammen mit einer Prise Salz, Zucker und Vanilleextrakt
in der Küchenmaschine cremig schlagen, so ungefähr 4-5min.
Und die ganz genauen Mengenangaben, die schreibe ich euch wie immer unten in die Videobeschreibung.
Und falls ihr jetzt keine Küchenmaschine habt: gar kein Problem!
Dann verwendet ihr ganz einfach euer Handrührgerät.
Das dauert dann so 1-2min länger aber es funktioniert auf jeden Fall auch.
Ich habe in der Zwischenzeit Milch und Öl abgewogen
und das auch noch ganz kurz am Ende mit untergerührt. Das braucht wirklich nur 5-6sek.
Und als nächstes kommen die trockenen Zutaten dazu, das ist einfach nur Mehl und Backpulver.
Ich mach das gern so, dass ich das vorab richtig schön miteinander verrühre
damit ich auch ganz genau weiß, dass es sich gut verbunden hat.
Diese trockene Masse siebe ich jetzt noch mit zur Eiermasse
und werde sie auch nur ganz kurz unterrühren.
Also wirklich nur ein paar Sekunden bis es sich zu einer homogenen Masse verbunden hat
und dann ist der Teig auch schon fertig.
So, und jetzt nur ganz kurz.
So, das waren jetzt nur 10sek.
Ich mach's aber gerne so, dass ich nochmal mit dem Schneebesen einmal unten nachschaue.
Ja, es hat sich alles gut verbunden. Perfekt!
So, jetzt habe ich hier auch noch meinen Backrahmen vorbereitet. Ich habe unten drunter mein Backblech,
ein Backpapier obendrauf und den Backrahmen habe ich festgeklemmt auf..
[Kiki] 26x...was haben wir hier Hamza?
[Hamza] 36!
[Kiki] Genau, x36cm, genau.
Ich schreibe auch das aber auch noch mal in die - Ich muss da reingucken!
Ich schreibe euch das aber auch nochmal in die Videobeschreibung.
Wie gefällt euch denn unsere neue Kameratechnik? Schreibt's mir doch mal bitte in die Kommentare!
Ja, es ist so- Ich weiß nicht wo - naja!
Also ich gucke immer da rein.
Hamza ist mal da, mal da, deswegen spreche ich auch manchmal da zu dir, Hamza.
Und manchmal stehst du da hinten.
Also mir gefällt's ganz gut, wir müssen uns halt tatsächlich noch ein bisschen eingrooven.
Aber schreibt mir doch bitte mal euer Feedback in die Kommentare, das würde mich nämlich sehr interessieren!
So, und ich gebe da jetzt einmal den Teig rein, streiche den noch ein bisschen glatt
und dann wird er gebacken. Ofen habe ich schon vorgeheizt, 180° C Ober- und Unterhitze
und da braucht der Teig bis er gar ist so um die 20min, maximal 21.
Und dann mache ich in der Zwischenzeit schonmal die leckere Tränke.
Mit ganz viel Milch, dat wird richtig lecker Leute!
So, ich zeige euch jetzt in der Zwischenzeit, wie wir diese leckere Flüssigkeit machen,
in die wir unseren Teig gleich einmal reindippen.
Dafür brauchen wir Milch.
Ich stehe jetzt hier am Herd, denn wir müssen gleich Schokolade schmelzen und das mache ich direkt in der Milch.
Also schön viel Milch reingeben. Dann habe ich hier gezuckerte Kondensmilch.
Übrigens: Ihr wisst ja, ich bin ein Kaufland Fan
und in diesem Video benutze ich ganz viele Kaufland Zutaten, das heißt ihr könnt euch eigentlich unten in der Infobox
gleich einen Screenshot machen von den Zutaten und dann wenn ihr mögt, ab zu Kaufland und dort einkaufen gehen.
Ich gebe jetzt hier einmal die Kondensmilch noch rein, da brauche ich aber nur die halbe Dose.
Und die andere lagere ich einfach im Kühlschrank, die hält nämlich im Kühlschrank Ewigkeiten.
Da wird sich bestimmt ein Rezept finden, wo ich wieder Kondensmilch benutzen muss.
Dann habe ich hier Erdbeersirup, ganz viel davon.
Das ist so hauptsächlich jetzt hier Geschmacksträger finde ich,
also der macht sich richtig bemerkbar.
Und nochmal für die Süße und auch nochmal für den Geschmack
habe ich jetzt hier auch noch weiße Schokolade, Bourbon Vanille Geschmack.
Und das mache ich jetzt klein und gebe das auch noch mit dazu.
[Kiki] Bitte, wie hübsch sieht diese Tafel aus?!
[Hamza] Das sieht aus wie so ein Tor, wie so'ne Sonne, ne?
[Kiki] Wie so Sonnen, genau!
[Hamza] Sonnenaufgang!
[Kiki] Ja, passt doch perfekt zum Rezept. Schön sommerlich!
So, jetzt einmal den Herd einschalten.
Nicht die höchste Stufe, ich nehme jetzt einfach 7 von 9.
Und dann warten wir bis die Schokolade hier schön schmilzt.
So, und weil das Auge mitisst, gibt's jetzt noch ein bisschen rote Lebensmittelfarbe.
Ist aber nur optional, also nur wenn ihr mögt.
[Kiki] Naja, es ist jetzt eher pink statt rot! *lacht*
[Hamza] Für mich ist pink und rot das gleiche!
So, die Milchmischung, die ist jetzt eher lauwarm.
Also ganz so heiß sollte sie nicht sein. Falls sie doch zu heiß geraten ist, dann auf jeden Fall abkühlen lassen.
Ich fülle das jetzt hier um.
Hauptsächlich damit ihr etwas sehen könnt, in dem Topf kann man ja nichts sehen.
So, und mein Kuchen ist auch schon fertig gebacken.
Der ist gerade aus dem Ofen gekommen, bzw. eigentlich vor 5min schon.
Ich hatte ihn zugedeckt nochmal 5min stehen lassen damit der noch so ein bisschen ausdampfen kann.
So, und als nächstes werde ich jetzt einmal den Backrahmen lösen
bzw. ich glaube, ich nehme ihn erstmal hier runter.
Schiebe ich jetzt einfach mal runter.
So, das geht auch ganz schnell.
Und dann nehme ich mir persönlich jetzt meinen Backformlöser, damit ich mir hier auch nichts kaputt mache.
Einmal die Ränder schön lösen.
Der Teig, der mag den Rand der Backform doch ganz schön!
Und so ist der jetzt ab, jetzt noch die Klemmung einmal abmachen
und dann nehme ich den Backrahmen weg und den werde ich jetzt noch lauwarm in Stücke schneiden.
Entweder macht ihr das jetzt nach Augenmaß oder ihr nehmt euch eine Teigkarte mit 'nem Maß oder ein Lineal
oder einen Torteneinteiler, das mache ich jetzt hier eben.
Oh Hamzaa! Da werden wieder Ränder übrig sein!
[Hamza] Geil!
*Ofen läutet*
[Kiki] Siehst du, der Ofen freut sich auch schon!
So, und jetzt werde ich mir ein Messer nehmen.
Das ist so ein einfaches Messer, hat einen Wellenschliff. Damit kann ich immer besonders gut schneiden.
Und jetzt schneide ich hier einfach die Quadrate.
Der Teig ist übrigens sehr fluffig, ich glaube das sieht man schon!
[Hamza] Das sieht man direkt, ja!
[Kiki] Guck mal, wie ich hier so durchgleite!
So, ich hab's fertig durchgeschnitten
und jetzt nehme ich mir eine große Schüssel und gebe da Kokosraspeln mit rein.
Ich hab mir sogar überlegt: Eigentlich könnte man die Kokosraspeln sogar rosa färben.
Aber ich guck erstmal wie's so aussieht und wenn's mir dann optisch gefällt, dann lass ich's auch so.
Also ich werde die 2. Kokosraspel-Packung mit Sicherheit auch brauchen aber ich nehme jetzt erstmal nur eine.
Weil manchmal verklumpt sich das durch die Milch so ein bisschen
und dann ist es einfacher, erstmal nur die eine Packung zu öffnen.
So, jetzt mache ich mir ein bisschen Platz. Und dann - sieht man's so noch Hamza?
[Hamza] M-hm!
So, ihr könnt euch jetzt noch eine Palette nehmen
um untendrunter auch den Kuchen gut vom Backpapier zu lösen.
Und jetzt in die Milch.
Es ist besser wenn sie abgekühlt, denn unser Boden ist noch relativ lauwarm.
Das ist in Ordnung aber wenn die Milch jetzt zu warm ist und auf den sehr soften Boden trifft,
oder auf den sehr soften Kuchen, kann es sein, dass euch der Kuchen kaputt geht.
Ich tunke den jetzt hier ganz kurz rein, lasse es abtropfen
und gebe das dann in die Kokosraspeln und dann einmal richtig schön rundherum..
Es ist schon sehr soft.
Also wenn ihr das in Kokosraspeln ummantelt, dann nehmt eure Hände. Es ist schon sehr weich.
Und legt das hier ab, perfekt.
So, ich kann euch jetzt 2 entscheidende Tipps geben für Zuhause.
1. Die Würfel, also diese Teigwürfel wirklich nur ½sek in die Flüssigkeit tunken.
Also wirklich rein, raus und abtropfen lassen.
Und nicht irgendwie 1-2sek.
Das war bei meinem Schoko Cupavci der Fall, da konnte man das ein bisschen länger drin lassen
aber das ist halt ein ganz anderes Rezept.
Daher wirklich nur kurz und ganz vorsichtig weil der Boden ist so fluffig,
dass er dazu neigt, sonst auseinander zu fallen.
Und dann der 2. Tipp:
Am besten ist es tatsächlich, wenn alles schön abgekühlt ist
und natürlich werde ich diese ganzen Würfel gleich nochmal in den Kühlschrank geben.
Ich denke mal so 1h müsste reichen wenn ihr grad im Zeitdruck seid.
Wenn ihr mehr Zeit habt, dann macht das gerne morgens schon für abends oder macht das gerne am Vortag
denn ich finde je länger sie ziehen, desto besser.
Und dann kann man auch schon genießen. Ich werde sie übrigens noch mit
- habe ich mir nämlich gerade überlegt - mit Erdbeeren und frischer Minze dekorieren.
Ich werd die Sauerei gleich hier noch erstmal aufräumen.
Und euch werde ich jetzt schonmal an der Stelle verabschieden
aber ich habe gehört der Hamza macht noch einen Taste Test!
[Hamza] Oh yes, my Dame! My Dame!
[Kiki] My Dame! *lacht*
Was Bruder? Was soll ich sagen Bruder?
Wir haben zwar hinter der Kamera gerade schon die ganze Zeit gegessen,
ich glaube, ich hab schon so 2 Stück davon intus aber Hamza probiert gleich nochmal für euch und macht den Taste Test.
Und dann wünsche ich euch ganz viel Freude beim Nachbacken.
Denkt dran: Wenn ihr das Ganze nachgemacht habt,
dann teilt eure Fotos und markiert mich mit dem Hashtag oder auch mit dem Profil kikiskitchen
und dann kann ich das Ganze reposten und mir angucken auf Instagram oder auf Facebook.
Aber ich glaube, Facebook stirbt langsam so ein bisschen aus.
Also, ich wünsche euch viel Spaß und sage: Bis zum nächsten Mal auf Kikis Kitchen, Tschüss!
[Hamza] So, Taste Test! Geh mal weg!
[Kiki] Hamza macht jetzt den Taste - oh, warte!
[Kiki] Meine Damen und Herren, jetzt folgt der Taste Test!
[Hamza] Du machst alles jetzt lächerlich und das ist peinlich!
[Kiki] Nein! Jetzt darfst du anfangen.
[Hamza] Ich glaube ich hab gespuckt!
Also Leute, Taste Test!
Ich liebe Cupavci, mit Schokolade zumindest. Das habe ich noch nie probiert, mal schauen, wie das schmeckt.
Also von der Konsistenz weiß ich ja, es ist sehr fluffig. Das wissen wir alle, ne?
Kiki, das ist echt so ein richtiges Gender Reveal Ding. Ohne Witz, ne?
Also wenn du's in blau noch machen würdest..
[Kiki] Eigentlich echt 'ne coole Idee! Blau für 'nen Jungen und rosa für 'n Mädel dann.
M-hm, m-hm!
[Kiki] Und? Beschreib's mal mit 3 Worten!
[Hamza] Fruchtig!
Nennen Sie ein Land, in dem Olivenbäume wachsen.
Bolivien!
[Hamza] Also das ist voll die fruchtige Variante von Cupavci.
[Kiki] Ja!
Also, ich weiß nicht, gibt's sowas- Wo ist das her, Bosnien? Gibt's sowas eigentlich auch in Erdbeer? Hab ich noch nie gesehen!
[Kiki] Ich weiß es nicht. Ich hab's mir noch so überlegt aber ich hab's glaub ich auch noch nicht gesehen.
Also ich finde für jemanden, der mehr auf Frucht steht als auf Schokoladiges, ist das perfekt.
Sehr, sehr lecker Leute, schmeckt sehr, sehr fruchtig. Sehr weich.
[Kiki] Also passend zur Jahreszeit, ne? Schoko ist was für'n Winter und das ist was für'n Sommer, ne?
[Kiki] Und man sieht schon, dass der superweich ist.
[Hamza] M-hm, ein Kritikpunkt.
[Kiki] Ohh!
[Hamza] Einen!
[Kiki] Kamera ist aus, Kamera ist aus! Wir haben 'nen technischen Fehler, ups!
[Hamza] Cringe. Auf jeden Fall..
[Hamza] Weißt du, was schön wäre? Also es ist kein Kritikpunkt aber ich meine ja nur.
[Hamza] So 'ne Erdbeere, die du 2x anschneidest und dann drauflegst. Ne? Seien wir ehrlich, ne?
[Kiki] Darf ich kurz was dazu sagen?
[Hamza] Nein, ich red nur vom Optischen!
[Kiki] Nein, darf ich was dazu sagen?
[Hamza] Das ist halt instagrammable!
Und zwar, ihr müsst euch das so vorstellen: Ich wollte jetzt eigentlich noch frische Erdbeeren holen gehen.
Und ich hab das eigentlich schon gesagt. Also im Video habe ich gesagt: "So, dann dekoriere ich noch mit Erdbeeren und mit frischer Minze"
Und dann wollte ich das im Nachgang machen, nachdem diese Kühlzeit vorbei ist.
Und jetzt hat Hamza mich richtig hier geleaked, dass ich das noch nicht gemacht habe.
Also eigentlich war das so geplant.
Aber ich nehme natürlich jede Kritik an. Ich bin ein sehr kritikfähiger Mensch, sehr!
Sorry, hab ich nicht zugehört. Ich bin ein Mann, wie immer ne?
*beide lachen*
Ich bin ein Mann, ist normal bei uns! *lacht*
Also, Taste Test bestanden. Sehr lecker Leute, unbedingt nachmachen.
Ist halt was Anderes als die klassischen Cupavci.
Wie gesagt: Fruchtig, lecker, nachmachen.
Und abonnieren nicht vergessen Leute, ne? Ciao Ciao!
[Kiki] Tschüss!
[Hamza] Kiki hat noch ihr Ticket hier! *lacht*
[Kiki] Ja, ich weiß es doch! Ich weiß es doch!
Jaja, ne? Du bist eine von diesen Bloggern, die ein Mal anziehen und dann zurückschicken, ne?
Und dann so: "Ey Leute, guckt mal! Kauft euch das, das ist voll cool!"
*beide lachen*